how do you come up with who you
interview and you do you put out ads I
know Michael Moore has on occasion put
out ads when he's looking for subjects
and it works for him right because he
gets a billion viewers on his website
and you know I don't know how many
hundreds of thousands of followers on
Twitter and so it works for him for
someone like me not not so well but you
know I know the audience I know what the
content is going to be and just in its
when you're researching a project
researching a topic you naturally come
upon stories and individuals that are
sort of at the forefront of these topics
in the research and whatnot and so it
just comes up in the development phase
any start kind of compiling a list of
potential people and at some point I'll
start calling them and having
conversations with them and feeling them
out that way kind of pre-screen them you
know yeah eventually home them down and
is it a phone call versus an email um
yeah yeah typically email subjects or
potential candidates anyway at first
just to kind of introduce myself in the
project and that way I can link to the
website so they can familiarize
themselves and see that I'm a credible
you know person and not just some
schmuck wanting to do it in a
documentary and so yeah I start with the
email and then eventually get on the
phone and have kind of a more extended
conversation with them just to kind of
see how they speak or they articulate
enough today are they good at expressing
themselves they have a lot to say and
are they interesting you know the
interesting character interesting way of
speaking like all that kind of stuff
factors into who you pick to be the film
who's your email like do you keep it
shorter rather than longer yeah I try
and keep it short you know and you know
I link to the website a link to my
website a quick synopsis about what the
film's going to be about and that's it
you know that's kind of all they need to
know yeah don't
no overkill ologist yeah I think yeah I
think if you if you write long long
emails to people that you're introducing
yourself to it just seems kind of
desperate and you know it tends to turn
people off a little bit I think yeah
straight to the point straight to
business yeah
you